hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast herpes serology hsv-1 and
hsv-2 type specific diagnosis from the
public health perspective
I'm dr. Tiffany Mackenzie and I'm a
scientific affairs manager of infectious
disease and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by dias Oren design
is a global leader in the field of
biotechnology for more than 40 years the
company has been developing producing
and commercializing reagent kits for in
vitro diagnostics worldwide it offers
the broadest range of specialty tests
available in the immuno Diagnostics
market and continually invests in
research and development using its own
distinctive expertise in the field of
immuno Diagnostics to deliver a high
level of innovation for more information
about the asourian please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license oh we'll try
to answer as many questions live as we
can you can enlarge this slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
and finally if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button in
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left corner of
your webpage and follow the process to
obtain your credits and finally now I
would like to
reduce today's speaker my friend and
colleague dr. Richard STIs dr. Richard
sneeze is the public health laboratory
director for the state of Tennessee
Department of Health he comes to us
today with over 30 years of experience
in public health and is one of the
nation's leading Public Health
Laboratory experts he has also worked
internationally and provided support for
many organizations including the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention the
CDC the association of public health
laboratories aphl the American Society
for Microbiology ASM the clinical
laboratory standards institute cos I and
the US Department of the Interior DOI
for projects sponsored all over the
world in Asia the South Pacific and the
United States territories and Europe
among his multiple roles driving public
health initiatives dr. Smith has
recently served as the National
chlamydia laboratory coordinator for the
CDC national infertility prevention
project the IPP and a science advisor to
the aphl dr. Steve's is currently the
chair of the STD subcommittee for the
aphl and serves on several other key
aphl committees he is a board certified
diplomat of the American Academy of
microbiology ASM I will now turn it over
to dr. Richards fils for his
presentation thank you
keep setting I really appreciate that I
want to thank everyone for taking time
out of their busy schedule today to call
in and listen to this presentation and
in particular I'd like to thank the
asourian for the opportunity to be
spending some time with all of you here
this morning or this afternoon depending
upon what region of the country that
you're located in as you can see from
the slide the title of the presentation
today is herpes serology hsv-1 and hsv-2
type specific diagnosis from the public
health perspective and if we look at the
next slide we can look at the objectives
and for us to really understand the
recommendations and and all the issues
surrounding type-specific serological
testing we need to get on the same page
so we need to talk a little bit about
some of the other items related to her
lisa-marie screening it's like the
epidemiology of herpes infections a
little bit about the transmission the
pathology is from the clinical
manifestations we also need to describe
enough that's available to diagnose
hsv-1 and hsv-2 infections and the
difference between isolation and
identification versus serological assays
and the respective role in herpes
diagnosis we're going to talk about the
CDC sexually transmitted disease
treatment guidelines that were published
fairly recently in 2015 and talk about
the role and the appropriate use of
type-specific serological tests in
addition we're going to talk a little
bit more about the guidelines
recommendation as to why purpose type
specific screening should not be used at
this time in the general US population
well before we go into that I wanted to
put this slide up here this was an
article that it that appears and has
appeared in Cosmo table third magazine
and December 2015 and kind of followed
it as some fairly good health related
articles certainly on STDs I guess some
termination in there in the past and
this particular article is about her
piece and the title of it is are we too
afraid of her piece it's mostly a benign
skin condition that millions of people
have and that was the title of the
article in cosmopolitan individuals can
certainly check that out I'm sure
probably online or may have copies of
that but there were several quotes in
there they called it that I thought were
rather interesting and one of the quotes
in they are they call data that herpes
it's just a skin rash if you leave and
get the skin rash and also another court
it's ironic that herpes has a stigma but
nobody dies of it well I want you to
kind of keep these things in mind as we
go through the presentation today and at
the very end of the presentation maybe
we can visit this a little bit to see it
if maybe it's a little bit more
complicated than that or if maybe
there's just a little bit more to the
issues of herpes and herpes infections
let's start out with the epidemiology
today genital herpes is a chronic or
life mono viral infection once you're
infected with herpes virus you're
infected for life herpes virus just
loves to live but nerve cells and it can
go and hide there and persist for long
periods of time before it the conditions
are right and it may or may not reoccur
another may be an aggravation of the
original infection so once you have it
you have it forever there's two HSV
Cyril types hsv-1 and hsv-2 hsv-2 is
responsible for the majority of cases of
recurrent shinola produce in the United
States and then uh appears back we used
to say that hsv-2 was below the belt if
you will or genital infections and HSV
one was above the belt oral and order
higher bolivianos
type infections and in many areas of the
country that's still true however in
many areas of the country or in certain
populations you do see some differences
for example
in California you may see hsv-2 hsv-1 in
equal numbers below the bill and you can
see that in other certain populations
too MSM populations so you need to look
at your specific area your specific
population the people that you're
testing to determine whether hsv-1 or
HSV tias is more prominent about Airport
below-the-belt according to CDC is
approximately a million new cases of HSV
every year this estimated this is least
fifteen million individuals in the US
that have genital HSV infections and the
majority of persons infected with HSV to
have not been diagnosed with generally
so we're going to talk a little bit
about that throughout the presentation
of the tak that most herpes infections
are asymptomatic in the u.s.
approximately fifteen and a half percent
of adults between the ages of 14 and 49
have specific hsv-2
antibodies hsv-2 so prevalence is higher
in women and men in all age group and
varies by race and ethnicity and the big
thing to remember is the maturity of
genital herpes infections are
transmitted by persons unaware that
they're infected or asymptomatic when
transmission occurs so when I used to
get phone calls from individuals that
you know this SOB gave me herpes and I
know he had herpes or she knew I had her
she had herpes they probably didn't know
that they were actually infected they
probably were telling the truth it and
we're aware because again the majority
of the cases are asymptomatic so we're
going to talk about this throughout the
presentation this is slide from CDC it
kind of reinforces what we just talked
about the so prevalence in women is
higher than an old white women higher
than men
when I'm higher than in black men and
also the higher rates that we see in the
black population again another example
of racial inequities racial disparities
that we see with with some of the other
STDs in in addition to herpes so
transmission let's look at the
transmission hsv-1 and hsv-2 can both be
transmitted sexually and perinatally
there's really no difference between the
transmissibility between the two viruses
efficiency of sexual transmission is
greater from men to women and vice versa
and having general HSV infections
increase an individual's risk of
acquiring HIV infection twofold purpose
is not a particularly hard Eve iris is
not a particularly strong virus it's
very susceptible to drying so it's
readily inactivated by joining most
soaps inactivated herpes viruses
hydrogen peroxide alcohol a variety of
different agents can inactivate
atrophies fairly readily so for my
transmission is uncommon but it has been
documented so it doesn't trigger but not
very commonly because it it just doesn't
last long outside the human body
pathology we already talked about herpes
once you have herpes that remains with
you for life it remains latent it goes
back into the the nerve cells and it
just lives there just happy as a clam
until the next possibility or the next
type of stress causes it to come out and
reactivation as we know can be
precipitated by multiple unknown and
some known factors we've seen on college
campuses that for example as you get
closer to finals week or in the middle
of finals individuals with total sorts
and stress can pop that down so herpes
can certainly be reactivated by
stressful stressful conditions sunlight
or bad sunburns we also see that
sometimes triggers reactivation or
herpes virus in some individuals
hormonal changes monthly changes in
women can also trigger that and that's a
variety of other things that we know and
and things that we don't know that can
cause these reactivations of
herpes virus reactivation Navy visible
you may see the lesions or sub critical
viral shedding may occur primary
infections are generally more prolonged
and severe and that makes sense the body
hasn't seen the virus before you have no
mo no logical capabilities you have no
pre-existing antibodies no specific
cellular immunity and so when an
individual is infected in at first case
that primary infection antibodies take
time to develop your cellular immunity
takes time to develop and that come into
play so that's why your primary
infections are generally more prolonged
and severe secondary infections are
generally shorter another shorter
duration and hsv-2 may have more
recurrent infections that hsv-1 there to
work pragmatically this is important
that's one of the reasons when we get
into and the discussion about laboratory
tests we'll talk a little bit about
typing this virus and there's other
reasons why we want to type it too but
pragmatically is certainly one of those
this is a nice slide from CDC and it
kind of points out what we just kind of
talked about on the first episode of you
little gremlin website of the slight
infection type first episode primary
infection with type 1 or type 2 at that
time listen to the joke is not here and
not been exposed to hsv-1 are hsv-2 so
they have no pre-existing antibodies and
no pre-existing specific some of the
other immunity a case the lesions and
symptoms that are listed here can be
severe
and and certainly prolong an example of
the first episode in a non-primary case
the next lie and tie to where you have a
pre-existing hsv-1 infection it can
actually moderate that because there is
some cross protection and you can look
at this chart it is a good example of
why this occurs why when antibodies are
present and can modulate or turn it from
a more milder infection then that first
primary episode we talk about the
clinical manifestations and here we see
some primary revisions or case of
primary infection with these lesions the
penis and I want to point these up for a
couple of reasons one this is not when
when a lot of it is just think of four
pieces and especially individuals that
have had their headquarters you know how
the sick of it gets these diseases
started getting a little bit or they're
getting a little bit dried up and little
crusty these are not ideal lesions who
do I use for virus isolation you would
want to have fresh nice specifically
gence for that your success of getting
an isolate cell culture or a direct test
or PCR for that matter certainly
decrease the longer the infection goes
when the lesions are starting to dry and
crust up that's not the time now this is
a individual that says well you know I
get these every about every two three
months you can take the specimen but you
also want to tell into does you know
come back the next time early on when
these things are fascicular so we can
get a good specimen because that's the
if there's anything about it reoccurs
it's nice for the opportunity to try and
yet
isolates and to confirm that so these
again it not that not the best reasons
to actually try and get a nice little
probe this is a picture of a recurrent
ulcer clinical notification they you can
see the recurrent ulcer it's an ulcer
and
it doesn't look like a vesicular lesion
could certainly can confuse with
something else there's other things that
can cause ulcers and we're going to talk
a little bit about that confusion in
just like a couple minutes cervicitis we
talked about asymptomatic shedding it
was an individual at the case of
cervicitis that individual may be
feeling perfectly normal aches no pains
no fever no nothing and they have my
little shedding and be aware of it so
cases cervicitis
you can see why individuals have may
transmit this virus and not even be
aware that they're infected this slide
is actually a good slide and it shows
two two different things it's light on
the products and it smells nice
vesicular lesions these are the lesions
that you want to look for to get a nice
to click on a specimen from if you take
and aseptic ly break that lesion open
with a forceps or tweezers or whatever
you have in the clinic and you take that
swamp as long as it's not a cotton tip
which chefs
beware calcium alginate swab which all
can be toxic to herpes just a rayon or
Dacron swab and you be taking the soap
bed swab up at the fluid that's in these
particular lesions and rub the base of
those cells if you're not causing the
patient some discovered you're most
likely not collecting the specimen
vigorously enough so that's one thing
that you need remember if you you should
be causing the page a little bit of
discomfort to be collecting that
specimen properly if you take that
specimen properly at this stage put it
in specific little transport medium and
out of the lab and there's no huge
delays in getting that to the lab
you're going to get herpes virus on that
specimen almost all other tests that we
have will probably get a nice good
positive out of a nice fresh lesion like
this another thing to note that herpes
lesions can occur on any part of the
body there's been cases especially with
younger individuals of individuals Auto
inoculating themselves scratching and
picking it away at a cold sore and
scratching another area on the body and
trance infected and transmitting that
virus if there's a broken skin abrasions
and the virus gets on that particular
area through scratching or whatever it
can gain a foothold and it can infect so
you may see these potentially on any
area of the body we used to see an
occasional case generally hsv-1 indents
doing dental work and and Nicorette cut
you know in the knuckle area particular
and develop our piece Whitlow don't see
that as much as we used to see that
because people were a little bit more
cognizant of that and a little bit more
careful with drugs and HIV and other
types of infections now so we don't see
that it's common so we used to but it
can occur in any part of the body and
the dead giveaway
are these specific event Allegiance
they're very characteristic you see
something like this especially if a
patient comes in and says yeah yeah I
can piece every month you know I had
this three four times now in the last
year you know it's pretty much a dead
giveaway there's not much else that
looks like this that's going to reoccur
not much
so HSV diagnosed the clinical diagnosis
itself can be insensitive individual may
be asymptomatic as we saw from one of
the previous slides the cases cervicitis
individual certainly having a an episode
and may not have even known it at the
time so the clinician certainly is not
going to see that unless they're doing a
routine pelvic exam and then it was not
going to know when they're shedding so
they can be relatively insensitive just
looking and trying to find lesions and
certainly nonspecific when you see all
the lesions or one mole of lesion or an
ulcer that we saw earlier there
certainly could be confused with
something else or even something now
related to an infectious agent
so clinical diagnosis itself often needs
help
the key of course you see these
recurrence these particular legions
pretty diagnostic in this cases so
therefore clinical diagnosis should
always be confirmed by laboratory
testing using specific virology tests
culture or non culture or serological
tests some sort of test to confirm that
and the reason other than oftentimes a
clinician may or may not be sure when
they look at a lesion the second reason
is psychologically I've seen many
instances where an individual is
clinically diagnosed but they just be
infection but it's there's there's
something about taking a specimen and
sending it to the lab getting that or AB
result back and a clinician X economy
you have laboratory diagnosed herpes
herpes won't have is too whatever and
then going into the counseling message
you know here's what you need to do
here's how I mean adjust your lifestyle
etc oftentimes individuals seem to pay
more attention to that than just a
clinician saying oh yeah looks like a
herpes virus and may or may not come
with some specific counseling so those
two reasons I think it's extremely
important that you confirm this with
specific laboratory tests let's look at
some of those laboratory tests we have a
by rollin on culture which is long they
consider the gold standard and we also
see if you look at the bottom you can
see PCR the gold standard so and we just
confuse well we're not going to fuse
then we're going to talk a little bit
more about that as we go through these
but barrel clothes are wrong pens that
can consider the gold standard and it is
a good test and it's some of the
preferred tests for patients with fresh
genital ulcers or other fresh lesions
and it's still necessary to determine
antiviral resistance at this point in
time we don't know the specific
sequences we don't have techniques to
molecularly determine the antiviral
resistance patterns in herpes virus yeah
it's just a matter of time as we move
into the more into the molecular and the
sequence again that we probably will
have but at this point in time we still
need a culture to look at antiviral
resistance antigen detection or direct
detection from regions with the FAA or
possible some of the EIS CDC suggests
they may be slightly better than culture
for detecting HSV in healing lesions of
course that assumes that you're taking
that scab crust off and you're you know
really scraping and causing some
discomfort to obtain that specimen I
haven't seen any data to really strongly
support this but you know CDC suggested
that it may be
cytology as a mirror press Mir they're
insensitive and nonspecific
perhaps Pap test was not developed to
diagnose surface infections no nothing
you can I occasionally see a herpes
infection there but it shouldn't be you
specifically
HSV diagnosis PCR really has been the
replacing our culture for quite a long
time as the method of choice for HSV
it's extremely sensitive and we're going
to talk about the relative sensitivities
and specificities in a few minutes
it's certainly the preferred test pretty
taking a chesty and spinal fluid or
needle samples CNS type specimens look
at cell culture there's still
conventional culture there are sites
they're still doing conventional cell
culture the use of variety different
cells because they're looking for a lot
of viruses not just for these viruses
and there are systems that you should be
like shell but I also several different
viruses but also it looks specifically
for just herpes virus something might be
enzyme-linked that if I roam digital
normally well system of a Elvis system
from diagnostic hybrids but the one
thing that you want to remember in the
city CDC recommend disable and tight
with the DFA when you see ourselves on
the left part of the slightly nice
fibroblast cells uninfected and slides
and cells in the middle you can see the
Robbins cells you can see some giant
cells and you can look at it and you
could almost tell where the type of
cells and the cpe that it's herpes virus
and in many cases you can almost and
it's the type by almost by looking there
because wonder have these two but you
should confirm obviously with da you
can't even hundred percent so a nice DNA
to confirm that because they remember
prognostically
you're going to see more recurrences
with two than one and in addition the
information for your population that we
talked about a few minutes ago
50% of the cases are below the belt with
hsv-1 and hsv-2 in your particular
region the reason we know that is
because we typos so we know that
epidemiological information so it's
important for a couple of reasons
to type these and to differentiate
herpes one and her loose - and it's
currently the CDC recommendations also
that some of the advantages of cell
culture it does require my virus so you
need to get these at a fairly early
stage nice particular lesions take them
properly that we talked about a few
minutes ago and I think of those
infected cells and you need special
virus transport media a transport of the
right conditions it works very well it
can be used related at all locations
you know labia or buttocks wherever you
might find these lesions it has a high
specificity when you see the specific
CPE and according it by the blood cells
it's pretty difficult to mistake you
know herpes CPE from other types of
viruses that you might isolate no cells
or few exceptions but generally it's
pretty difficult not to be able to
identify that if by the way the cells
grow in cell culture in your specific
CPE and also we used to differentiate
hsv-1 and hsv-2 only talked about why
that's important and the antiviral
susceptibility testing we talked about
why that is important also some of the
disadvantages well it's comparatively
expensive certainly more expensive some
of the nine culture techniques there's
many variables as well the cells
themselves the medium the transport
condition
technically it's a little more difficult
than a culture test not useful with
asymptomatic patients you don't want to
routinely take and just a cervical a
urethra or swab type specimens when you
see no lesions so individuals are they
symptomatically shedding are potentially
asymptomatic Lee shedding and probably
not that
tests of choice for that there's
somewhat of a delayed turnaround time
also one of three days of ours has to
grow however if you take a good fresh
specimen transported in the right
conditions to the lab with the right
transport medium etc you're probably
going to see that virus in 24 hours
herpes likes to grow in most cells
actually frozen all cells it's not too
many cells that it doesn't grow in but
it does grow very well and it grows very
fast
certainly by three days you're going to
detect probably 95 to 99 percent of the
herpes infection since cell culture
occasionally I've detected positive
South 5 to 6 to 7 days but that's been
very rare and probably came from
specimens that were or their legions etc
but a fresh specimen usually a year the
viruses chew through your cells by the
next day very quick growing the
sensitivity can be low again as the
leaders begin to heal and you can get
false negative results in those
situations okay let's look at someone
and culture test well we already talked
about the direct smears it stains the
zinc smear are saying stain the faa in
the products it is and some of the
enzyme in molasses if we look at some of
the advantages they aren't really
relatively inexpensive and they're
fairly rapid but they're very
insensitive so they shouldn't certainly
should be used in critical situations
not with newborns regularly a minute
term or suspected encephalitis or see a
CSF or any critical type specimens and
the stains that saying it's a
nonspecific stain and they also require
lesions so there's several disadvantages
of these tests and they're not
recommended really at this point of time
the nucleic acid amplifying test
excellent tests one of the first ones
that was developed
PCR using the raw slate cycler Mayo
Clinic dr. Tom Smith and colleagues at
Mayo kind of developed this early
protocol at least one of the major sites
that were using this protocol they had
many workshops back several years ago
the American Society for microbial
mediums the clinical neurology symposium
and and really tried to transfer this
technology out into the virus labs I
remember attending a couple of workshops
with that dr. Smith and some of the crew
from nail relates to my psyche they work
very well and you can also type a time
that used a melting curve and you could
type and isolate from increased
sensitivity and specificity it was a
great little procedure and there's
procedure to still use that light cycler
and or other machines and amplification
methods Luminex
they called r-tx he likes a little
self-contained little plastic apparatus
contains everything cartridge and a
beanie protec every stomach virus k2 the
accent excellent amplified tests and
techniques for detecting HSV infections
the advantage is like I mentioned before
they're the most sensitive tests they
provide rapid turnaround time meaning
same-day results any and in most cases
you know have good they can be used to
differentiate hsv-1 from the hsv-2 and
it's definitely the tested choice for
looking for herpes and spinal fluid or
infections in the central nervous system
etc a place where you're more than
likely not going to find either by a
virus or not a lot of virus present it's
definitely recommended for those types
of specimens and it has high specificity
99 percent or greater some of the
disadvantage is depending on the version
it might not be suitable for large
volumes screening if you did lots of
herpes virus
it does require a high technical skill
although with the newer nucleic acid
amplify tests are getting to the point
where cell culture probably requires a
higher degree of technical skill than
medic like as an amplified test in most
cases special facilities are a clean
area while you no longer really special
facilities but you do need to keep kind
of a clean area getting more more
forgiving with again cartridges for
everything self-contained and much much
more able to run these on the regular
lab bench but you still ideally would
want to keep those in a nice clean area
anytime you're trying to do that look
like jessa they're fairly expensive
certainly one of the big drawbacks and
not all the Nets that are available are
FDA cleared
okay let's start talking about some of
the serological assays there are a
variety of different tests that are
available hsv-2 rapid tests the Fisher's
review hsv-2
it goes the old test from diet not and
technology that now fishery the Reuters
Fisher is either selling for them or
somebody want them out I don't see I
only see the Fisher name on it nowadays
and the herpes select Express hsv-2 from
focus and also the chemo luminescent
assay the lesson on the essaouira hsv-1
and hsv-2 type specific test so we're
going to talk about the difference
between the type specific here in a
minute and why that's critical enzyme
immunoassays herb you select one a few
from focus hsv-1 and two from Trinity
and there's other manufacturers that do
have out of summer recess Western Blatt
I'm not aware of any commercial Western
blot kit that maybe I'm not aware of any
when most Western blot as needed I know
some of the private labs some private
labs are doing at the University of
Washington probably is a leader in that
it's a very difficult test to
standardize and to read so people the
University of Washington will have
experience in doing western blots so if
you need to have a list of what for some
reason
you know you might want to consider that
very good at what they do
there's also there you select one into a
lot focus the only problem with that is
right now CDC doesn't recommend that
because it uses the same recombinant
antigens as they use in their enzyme a
little essay tests however one thing to
remember is what you do screening assay
even if you're using something that has
the same recombinant antigen a simple
repeat doesn't crease your positive
predictive value that's one of the
reasons that we do that like HIV we be
tested it increases our productivity
back that's just something to keep in
mind but currently it's not recommended
in the treatment guidelines serology
advantages of serology if the test is
designed like that yes or in some of the
other essays to detect glycoprotein 1 G
1 and G 2 you can't differentiate
between hsv-1 and hsv-2 infections we
served a lot of serologies for herpes
virus before glycoprotein one in
glycoprotein 2 and we're even identified
and we could detect antibodies but we
couldn't differentiate we couldn't tell
well there's one know whether it was 2
and what are those lesions that he saw
genital lesions that you saw and he
picked up a positive serology result
whether that really came from our who's
1 infection from from the lips whether
it really was related to HSV - so
without using a specific test that can
differentiate those two specific
antigens HSV serology is currently not
recommended so the tests that are
labetalol the sense that he doesn't vary
a bit between 80 to 90 percent the
specificity is in the high 90s and you
get rapid turnaround time again unique
same-day result with these tests there
were very good assets for doing what
they design to do they're moderately
expensive they're technically less than
concert tests and other antigen tests
and they may not distinguished
like a protein G 1 and G 2 depending on
the version so you need to make sure
that if you're requesting a serological
assay as a clinician that that test can
differentiate between those and that's
what you're asking that test to do I'm
not sure why you would want to know just
whether the HSV antibodies are not it
probably would provide very little
clinical information to you so make sure
that whatever site you're using does
utilize something that can differentiate
and and type hsv-1 and hsv-2 sarah
logically so where do we use the type of
specific serological tests according to
the CDC and Public Health
recommendations cases were recurrent
general symptoms or atypical symptoms
with negative HSV PCR repulsor occurred
to confirm clinical diagnosis without
laboratory confirmation to manage sex
partners of persons with genital herpes
especially in discordant couples and if
they just were the wife or perhaps a
husband as infected and the wife
opposite partner is not man Diesel's
especially in cases where they're
thinking about having children
white becoming pregnant if she's
negative zero negative and the husband
so positive for examples so to manage
those types of partners to provide
education and to eliminate some of the
risk factors that might be associated
with transmission from a positive
partner to a negative to a current
negative partner CDC also suggests that
type-specific serological tests should
be considered for persons presenting for
an STD evaluation especially in the
middle from multiple partners individual
is having multiple partners engaging in
high-risk activities they haven't been
evaluated before for STDs this would be
a good example than individually that
should be evaluated individuals that are
infected with HIV
MSM or men who have sex with men at an
increased risk for HIV infection
they participate - activities those
individual shows also a screen or
suggested that they be screen with type
specific asses however you can see why
screening and the general population is
currently not indicated because of the
amount of people that are shedders
asymptomatic setters and the amount of
people that have hsv-1 and hsv-2 at
different locations so spinning in the
general population at this time it's
probably not useful and certainly not
recommended by CDC at this point in time
IgM antibodies well IgM antibodies can
be detected and they can be detected in
primary HSV infections if you know it's
a primary infection unfortunately that'd
be very common to be able to know that
we're sure co-infection with another HSV
type hsv-1 in sir positive individuals
that are acquiring HSV - and a dual
infections IgM can also be produced by
GM computer reproduce be produced in
reactivated HSV infections
so therefore IgM antibodies are not a
reliable indicator primary HSV
infections and it's generally not
recommended at this time to screen using
IgM and IgG an antibody assay
most of the information or much of the
information that we talked about this
afternoon actually comes out of the CDC
STD treatment guidelines do you see
below the chapter or part of the
guidelines to talk about the principles
of managed by the general for herpes and
we're going to talk about some of those
again I mention this because these
recommendations are available online you
can go online at the CDC govt website
you can download base you can actually
order these from CDC and they have some
nice world charts also you can order so
there's some other materials that you
can get from CDC and to look at specific
recommendations policies but certainly
for the recommendations for genital
herpes and if you want more details and
/ and some of the things that we've gone
over this afternoon the guidelines are
going to provide a lot more detail by
we're going over this afternoon so
patient management what do we do for the
patient well counseling it's critical
constantly regarding the natural history
is that sexual and perinatal
transmission methods to reduce
transmission extremely important
individual needs did he talk to you
about lifestyle changes defining the
responsibilities that they have to their
sexual partners extremely important that
individuals communicate back and forth
one another the desert where some of the
how they can lower some the risk of
transmission after the use of condoms
for example and so there's a lot of
information and that's available again
on the CDC website but that counseling
should be an integral part of patient
management antiviral therapy well what
does antiviral one out there for your
chemotherapy yeah well I can control or
partially control the signs and symptoms
of herpes
a couple things to remember it does not
eradicate latent virus may cause the
virus did have a shortened of course
infection and it may keep the virus from
recurring quite as many times it does
not eliminate the virus once you've had
the virus you will continue to have that
virus it will not eliminate that virus
from the body also it does not affect
the risk the frequency or severity of
recurrences after the drug is
discontinued when the drug is
discontinued herpes can reactivate at
any point in time and it can certainly
even when they're on a suppressive
therapy but maybe just for lesser time
period but when that drug is taken away
you go back patient gives you your space
or step one antiviral medications and we
have some excellent antiviral chemo
therapies available to us the cycle
there is generally this the first
chemotherapy antiviral chemotherapy of
choice that most cycle of here and damn
cycle appear and I generally topical
therapy with antiviral drug versus is
generally not recommended in most cases
CDC recommend the regimen for a first
clinical episode as the anti viral
chemotherapy beauty community choice is
that cycle of year either in 400 over
200 milligrams either three or five
times a day for seven to ten days
followed by a Bella cycle appear in
phencyclidine the case of the first
clinical episode depending from the
severity of that and again for more
specific information consult that the
the guidelines antiviral therapy can be
considered for suppressive therapy for
recurrent general herpes can also be
considered for episodic therapy for
recurrent genital herpes and treatment
severe diseases and in the case of
really severe disseminated herpes virus
and those recommendations are all in the
guidelines general herpes during
pregnancy most mothers are there but
some acquire Neil never heard these lack
histories of clinically
genital herpes yet most individuals are
asymptomatic or infected and don't know
they're infected the risk for the
transmission to the neonate is high 30
to 50 percent among women who acquire
general her Beast near the time of
delivery or at the time of delivery risk
individuals you know dates that are born
from an infected mother they do acquire
a herpes infection have a high
probability high mortality and morbidity
so herpes does it is associated with
mortality and it's also associated with
mortality it was in case of herpes
encephalitis not real common but it does
happen in women with histories of
recurrent herpes or acquired genital
herpes during the first half of
pregnancy over 4 the risk is fairly low
for transmitting that for the neonate
prevention of neonatal herpes and
depends on of waiting acquisition during
the late pregnancy avoiding exposure of
the events of legions during delivery if
they are present so all pregnant women
to certainly be asked whether they have
a history of general her these vary not
only asked but as specific questions
event that they ever experienced lesions
and the lesions here etc so very little
history should be taken and again
there's more recommendations in the
guidelines on how to handle and how to
avoid and how to treat neonates that
aren't affected with herpes so in
conclusion its herpes just a benign skin
condition or something that we should
take serious what we talked about a lot
of serious things here today and so I
think you have to answer that question
yourself an excellent should individuals
infected everything a big H on their
forehead well of course not there
shouldn't be a stigma because there's so
many people that are infected with
herpes
versus it's not the end of the world and
if it was still need to receive the
correct counseling and messages is it
true that nobody dies from herpes
infections well that's not true
we do know that individuals do die from
herpes infections in particular infants
that are infected during the birth
process from an infected mother so it is
a big deal so it is true that through
appropriate testing proper education
patient management and counseling
individuals should be able to live a
healthy normal life without guilt
so we answered all the questions that
were brought up Cosmo oh I'm not sure I
guess we think we can take a look at
that ourselves so at this point like the
end the presentation if there's any
questions that we'd like to try and
answer those thank you very much for
your attendance today
Thank You dr. Steve for that brilliant
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button in the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions live as we can
and our first question for dr. Spieth is
could you please go over dr. Spieth if a
woman has an outbreak of HIV at delivery
what are the recommendations yeah good
question it remember from the
presentation CDC reminds us that you
know all pregnant women should be asked
whether they have a history of genital
herpes and examined carefully especially
at the onset of labor and women without
symptoms or signs of general herpes
warts proteome can can deliver vaginally
although c-section does not completely
anem ly eliminate the risk for HSV
transmission to the neonate women with
recurrent genital herpes lesions at the
onset of labor should deliver by
c-section to reduce the risk of the
neonatal HSV infection from occurring
and that's right out of the CDC
guidelines so there's a little bit more
information in there if you want to
follow up and read up on that a little
bit but I think that probably answers
the question for you wonderful thank you
for that dr. Steve next question a
really quick definition question you
referred to on the transmission slide
slide eight to four might can you define
what for my transmission is sure oh my
sir
generally inanimate objects that are
capable of transmitting infections to
humans things like doorknobs toys or in
the case of HSV may be sexual toys you
know etc so any in an inanimate object
that somebody would COFF on or
contaminate somehow that could transmit
an illness or a disease to a human
okay great next question here the person
writing in asked my understanding of
difference between hsv-1 and two is that
if you get HSC one below the belt it is
only a one time infection or outbreak
whereas hsv-2 in the oral oral area is
only a one time infection or outbreak is
this true entirely hsv-2 certainly has
more recurrence and prognostically you
know that the chances of it recurring
more frequently or it or it regularly
regular intervals is certainly more
common than hsv-1 and an individual
that's infected below the belt if you
will they just see one they may see a
single outbreak but generally they'll
see a recurrence but rather than five to
six perhaps a year or or five to even a
dozen a year it may be you know one or
two certainly reduce occurrence if they
if they do appear so they do occur not
as common but they do and generally less
frequency if they do reoccur it's a
really interesting informative response
thank you and to the next question
is it easy to do molecular molecular or
polymerase chain reaction testing of
hsv-1 or hsv-2 in the blood well as far
as the ease of doing PCR course you know
PCRs PCR I mean it's pretty easy to do
in blood or any other types of specimens
I think with the question you're
probably asking is that is it a good
specimen - it's blood a good specimen to
test for hsv-1 or HSV - going to click
acid amplification and I you know
there's not a lot of data because we
don't routinely test that you know it's
more like spinals or or infants and
secretions and body body tissues and etc
generally with most viruses there's a
very short by reaming stage if there
even is one so I would say you know it
would not be a specimen of choice could
it ever be detected in blood well
certainly in cases of infant
disseminated conditions etc but
I think it would be very poor choice to
consider using under routine
circumstances thank you for your input
on utility of molecular testing and
different sample types this next
question is an excellent excellent point
what clinical advantage is there to
knowing if a patient has HSV one versus
HSV to again you know kind of what we
said in the presentation prognostically
you know HSV one it genitally certainly
below-the-belt tends to recur less
frequently and certainly less severe in
most cases than HSV - so prognostically
is probably the the the biggest reason
and of course we did mention you know
that kind of the epidemiology reasons of
being able to differentiate so you could
kind of know in your population you know
what you were seeing so so probably the
prognostic difference would be the major
reason to know whether it's HSC one or
two excellent so going back to more of a
public health question how effective our
condoms in preventing the spread of HSV
I know you touched on it but do you mind
going over that again sure that's
actually a really good question
basically CDC says and has the data to
support the condoms when they're used
consistently and correctly they can
reduce but not eliminate the risks for
genital herpes transmission is we have
to remember the most of most cases of
herpes are transmitted by persons
unaware that they're infected or are
asymptomatic so individuals most likely
would not be using condoms in those
cases anyway in addition since lesions
can appear in different areas of the
body
you know the condoms only only going to
be able to protect what it covers so
they can be very effective depending
upon where the lesions are and how
they're used but they will not eliminate
the risk completely
excellent thank you for making that
point next question about serology this
is an excellent point about indications
as you consider serologic assays you
consider them that they should be
recommended to test pediatric or
immunocompromised patients and I think
what I would what I would say is I would
refer you to the guidelines and then the
guidelines do recommend you know an
animal immunocompromised especially
individuals of history so there's a lot
of combination information that you
would look for as to whether you'd want
to make that decision and so I suggest
you know you can look into the
guidelines you know for more specifics
on that and of course any of these
should be discussed with the individual
clinicians the the basis clinicians too
so so I would refer you back to the
guidelines for more specifics on where
they actually do recommend that these be
tested okay excellent thank you for
referring us back to the guidelines
another interesting question about HSV
types so are there more types of HSV for
example three four and so on we spoke
about agency wanted to type specific
tests today but can you speak about
other serology type sure well you
remember when we look back when we first
started identifying herpes viruses
herpes one herpes to a couple of first
viruses that we identified
varicella-zoster chickenpox son Omega
virus epstein-barr there on the herpes
virus groups and as we discovered new
ones we started numbering those so if we
do now then the norman glacier is
actually you know to refer those there
just by their serial type and they all
cause a variety of different things you
know and there are specific tests both
isolation and nucleic acid amplification
tests and serologies for for the other
ones like chickenpox settle make love
iris etc so there are there are multiple
herpes viruses and now you may see them
referred to as
as humans human herpes virus 3 or human
herpes virus four or five but that just
relates back to the in most cases to the
ones that we've already known existed in
a couple of the new ones that we've you
know discovered that were caused by
herpes viruses so so it's just kind of a
kind of a different nomenclature for for
some of the viruses that we've already
named well I think we have time for just
one more question which want to be
mindful of everyone's time so I have one
more a really excellent serology
question here so dr. Steve you indicated
the serology tests having sensitivity
with an eighty to ninety percent
currently FDA is asking for at least
ninety five percent sensitivity in
comparison against Western blots or
immuno blots and five ten caves of
missions could you please comment on
this well I think when you look at the
serological assays that have been
submitted in the past oftentimes FDA's
criteria you know is changed over time
and when a test gets FDA cleared and you
know I find it's very uncommon for FDA
when they do come out with changes or
more restrictions to go back and and
decertify or
not or are unclear a specific test so
there there have been tests and there's
a lot of tests that are that are FDA
cleared and been through the processors
tested that are not specific for hsv-1
and hsv-2 that are FDA cleared so I
think it's probably good that FDA
continues to look at this and trying to
raise the standards and to provide
reasonable guidance to sites that you
know it certainly doesn't prevent older
tests you know that have been FDA
cleared with less sensitivity and
specificity to still be available or on
the market if you will so I guess among
stories it's a good thing that that FDA
is constantly doing this and evaluating
it and it just you know makes those
tests
you know reform even better with the
input that they get from the old test
and from individuals that are doing
these so so I think it's a good deal
that they that they do look at these and
occasionally change their standards but
it still doesn't get rid of a lot of the
tests that were already cleared out
there that's an excellent answer as dr.
Stephen thank you so much speaking to
the increasing standards of the FDA and
how we manage those tests that are
currently cleared and raising the
standards for the next generation so if
there are no more questions I know there
are a number of questions actually that
we didn't get to in there excellent and
we will address those doctors speech and
I will address those as quickly as
possible following this webinar but if
they're just in to be mindful of time
we're going to wrap this up but I just
want to once again thank dr. Richard
Steig for his excellent presentation and
I just want to double check with you dr.
C's do you have any other final comments
you'd like to make before we wrap this
up today no other than if anybody has
any follow-up questions please you know
address them you know to in a proper way
back to the website either to Tiffany or
myself well we will certainly be glad to
answer those for you well excellent
thank you so much dr. Steve and I also
like to thank our sponsor dia Sauron for
making today's educational webcast
possible and just as a reminder today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September 17th 2016 you
will receive an email from laberd's
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay and we invite you
to forward this on to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
so thank you so much everyone for
attending it was really our pleasure and
have a great day